this reality is divine you are not here
as an accident
everything has deep meaning and purpose
you are here for a very specific reason
you have important lessons to integrate
you have crucial gifts to bring to the
world there is nothing more paramount
for you than to actualize those gifts to
individuate yourself as a beautiful
expression of human creativity and to
bring value to your family to the
community to the collective once we
begin thinking and experiencing reality
metaphysically always thinking about the
nature of reality we begin understanding
the meaning and the purpose of this
reality being made why we are here and
who we truly are and why we made this
[Music]
every single interaction in your life
has a deep meaning and purpose
everything serves as a beautiful lesson
for you something for you to learn in
your experience and then you also get to
share what you've learned with other
people and the next generations every
trauma every suffering serves as a
unique gift as a unique treasure for you
to have learn something profound and
then for you to be able to master your
conscious experience of that and become
wiser and become a teacher becoming a
student of life thinking metaphysically
all the time who am I truly why am I
here
what lessons am I to learn from reality
how can I experience reality every
moment as a school learning from every
single interaction and what is my unique
gift what did I come here to do to bring
a unique contribution to myself to my
family to the community and to the
collective and thinking this way is
exactly
cure to nihilism
and it's also exactly the truth and the
more this is embodied the more we can
collectively prosper and flourish
[Music]
much love
[Music]
[Music]